foreign
I've also listened to extensive
representations about the challenges
facing the social care sector
it did a heroic job looking after
children disabled adults and older
people during the pandemic
it's 1.6 million employees work
incredibly hard but even outside the
pandemic the increasing number of over
80s is putting massive pressure on their
services
I also heard very real concerns from
local authorities particularly about
their ability to deliver the dill not
reforms immediately
so I will delay the implementation of
this important reform for two years
allocating the funding to allow local
authorities to provide more care
packages
I also want the social care system to
help free up some of the Thirteen and a
half thousand hospital beds that are
occupied by those who should be at home
so I've decided to allocate for adult
social care additional grant funding of
one billion pounds next year and 1.7
billion pounds the year after combined
combined with savings from the delayed
still not reforms and more council tax
flexibilities this means an increase in
funding available for the social care
sector of up to 2.8 billion pounds next
year and 4.7 billion pounds the year
after that's a big increase
but how we look after our most
vulnerable citizens is not just a
practical issue it speaks to our values
as a society so does today's decision
will allow the social care system to
deliver an estimated 200 000 more care
packages over the next two years the
biggest increase in funding under any
government of any color in history
[Applause]